we got to keep pushing them
uh and speaking of pushing them larry
elder who brought me back on the grid
yesterday he referenced uh an interview
that he did with bill maher on his show
in 2013 this is larry elder's radio show
about nine years ago when he got into it
a little bit with bill maher over what
is a libertarian and can bill call
himself a libertarian and they have a
somewhat respectful gets a little tense
but somewhat respectful conversation
about it and this is what i mean about
defending what you believe saying it
honestly and clearly here's larry elder
and bill maher nine years ago i have a
request and i mean it bill with all due
sincerity you and i have seen each other
around town a little bit i've always
liked you personally
please tell me why you can why you
insist on calling yourself a libertarian
when you are in favor of affirmative
action you are in favor of gun control
you've constantly railed against ronald
reagan and george bush for tax cuts
against the rich
you
oppose airline deregulation you oppose
power regulation and for crying out loud
you voted for ralph nader and most
libertarians i know would sooner vote
for rasputin than ralph nader please
stop calling yourself a libertarian you
know it's always amused me uh larry that
every other political party is allowed
to have a big tent but the libertarians
who you can't even define most people
wouldn't even on the street tell you
what the word means we all have to march
in lockstep
behind certainly elders certain things
are not negotiable you support minimum
wage you support affirmative action
these are not negotiable there's a
libertarian party platform you can go
online and read it libertarianparty.org
republican party platform that plenty of
people vote republican and don't believe
half of it that's what politics isn't
american
core values that you have to have as a
libertarian and one of them is adherence
to to article 1 section 8 of the
constitution and the things that you
want especially gun control affirmative
action are absolutely inconsistent with
that you are not a libertarian bill
you're a progressive or a liberal i
don't know what you are but you're not a
libertarian
okay so it gets a little heated there at
the end and so be it but the reason i
wanted to show you that is because nine
years ago larry elder was trying to sort
of show bill maher hey you know in
essence he's saying hey you don't seem
to love the government right because you
want to smoke weed you want to live life
however you want to live it you want to
say whatever you want to say and not
fear the government is going to come get
you and all of those things
and
so why do you call yourself a
libertarian now bill actually makes a
good point that you should have big
tents across the board that i believe
right like what am i what am i trying to
do right now what have i been trying to
do for the last two years at this point
it's that i believe that the republicans
can be a really big wide tent that are
going to have more of the social
libertarian say people like me and then
can you fit that with the religious
conservatives this is this is tough
stuff that has to get worked out okay so
bill to that extent i think he's right
like you can you can have libertarian
beliefs and does that fit within a
libertarian party okay there's something
to be said there but then larry counters
that with well wait a minute just in
essence what he's saying is hey well
just because you want to smoke weed you
can't be for
high taxes you can't be for a lot of the
other big government stuff that you
seemingly are for and against the people
who come in and fix a lot of that stuff